okay so let's get started welcome to
lecture number 16 of the course and we
more or less start where we had stopped
in the last lecture so we're still
working with operator learning so which
means that we have a abstract PD of this
form and uh we are interested in
learning the solution operator the
operator G that Maps the inputs x to the
solution of the PD y right so this is
the basic idea and so far we have seen a
whole plethora of operative learning
algorithms whether it is CNN or DEET fos
CNO and so on they have different
features different attributes uh
different uh strengths and
weaknesses but uh the point that we have
been doing in the last lecture was to
look at what are time dependent buts and
this would be the starting point of
today's lecture so what is special about
time dependent problems so first of all
this dep relies on time dependent PD so
that's the first first
thing and the abstract form is given by
this right so this is the abstract form
so perhaps in the last lecture I did not
mention it explicitly but example a
typical example would be the heat
equation so you have U T minus llan of U
equal to 0 and U at x0 is U of X or U
Bar so this is a typical example of of a
Time dependent B another typical example
which a prior is not in this particular
form is given by the wave equation so
this is the heat
equation but if you consider the wave
equation the wave equation models the
propagation of waves in different media
let's say for a uniform medium so utt
minus L of U equal z u at x0 is some I
should have said V
perhaps um okay
because sorry for the notational
confusion so we are dealing with the
wave equation just to illustrate the
Beast that we have to
confront and here the displacement vtt
is equal to a minus of v = to0 v at x0
is some V bar and VT at x0 is equal to W
bar so a priority it doesn't look like
that this equation here the wave
equation is fitting this format right
but of course many of you perhaps know
this this there's a simple trick by
which you can you can put one in the
form of the other and the trick is
simply to identify what is called the
velocity VT with the w so then you can
rewrite the equation as uh sorry you can
reite the equation as U equals to sorry
VT is equal to W and WT is equal to the
laian of
uh B right and then you are back in this
form so you can write even high order
time derivatives in the form of first
order time derivatives by simply
expanding everything into a system in
other words your U your unknown now is V
and W so that solves the problem so any
time dependent PD can be written in this
abstract form good so what is the
solution operator this is what we were
looking at in the last lecture so the
solution operator is now a mapping which
takes into account not just functional
input but also the time so time T is one
of the inputs to this solution operator
and it turns out the solution at a given
time T given that you input T and the
initial condition right so this is what
uh determines the whole thing so if you
think in terms of data so what you have
is trajectories so in other words uh of
course ideally we would like to have the
entire time history of the solution we
would like to have UT
for T greater than zero but of course in
uh practice we have to sample them at
discrete points nothing on the computer
can be continuous or continum so as a
consequence what you do is that you
start at the first time Step Zero time
step the first time step and so on and
so forth so whenever you generate data
numerically or through observations what
you really have is this kind of a let's
say a trajectory of the solution right
so what is the learning task as I said
so the the this is very very important
because not every algorithm fits into
this framework but that is what is
essential because when you when you
think of a solution operator of a Time
dependent pde all that you do is that
you give it the time and you give it the
initial conditions and it turns out the
solution at that particular time okay
and this is what uh I expressed here
that youve given the initial conditions
boundary conditions and so on other the
inputs to the PD you have to generate
the entire
trajectory the entire solution
trajectory for all times D so this is
sort of the the basis of this entire
method that you have to generate the
entire
trajectory and as I explained in the
last lecture you could do it with neural
operators you could have used either
direct or Auto regressive evaluation and
this was not efficient uh in any way
shape or form so what I had stopped with
in the last lecture and which is what I
want to start with again is to use what
is called lead time conditioning so this
is the principle here that you have to
give time as some sort of input channels
everywhere so let me try to explain that
a little more I I was a bit Hasty in the
last lecture so perhaps we can do this
so here is a typical example so you have
CNO this just an example it could be FN
it could be Depon net whatever and you
remember that we have a sequence of
layers which are stacked up together as
in any any neural operator so you start
off with the input uh and then you you
have this convolutional layers you have
the this residual layers and so on and
so forth so what you have to do now in
lead time conditioning is first and this
is um perhaps not as important as what
you have to do second but nevertheless
you have to provide the lead time itself
as an input Channel what do I mean by
that what I mean is that in the set of
inputs apart from the solution you also
have to provide the time so in other
words Let's uh think of this neural
operator some s star you have to give it
the time and you have to give it the
input right just like we did with the
solution operator because in the
solution operator you have to provide it
with the time to be able to Output the
solution at a given time so this is uh
bar for the course you need it
good so that is as I said for instance
you you try to give the time you try to
give the solution at some earlier time
and then it can produce a solution at a
lat time so this is at the very
beginning itself but remember that what
we are doing is that we are stacking up
lots of layers so even in a CNO some of
the largest models that we have we could
have anything between 20 and 30 layers
so what happens is that if you only give
time as a input at the very beginning
there is a potential that the effect of
this time is not properly propagated
right it has to take into account time
it has to take into account initial data
so time is just an additional channel so
this is an additional
Channel it has to take into account the
input data it has to take into account
various things so what happens as a
consequence is that you have to somehow
keep the information about the time in
subsequent layers and this is where one
has to add or one has to modify what are
called normalization
layers so remember that uh at least in
the practice of deep learning uh in the
tutorials you have seen it that you
always have to normalize data right so
whenever you have to give an input to
the machine Learning System uh in order
to sort of Recon the different scales in
order to enable the gradient to
propagate smoothly so what one does is
that one tries to normalize the inputs
let's say between minus one and 1 is the
typical range for normalization now what
layer normaliz or so this is what you do
at the level of the input right but what
one does also is that after each layer
you keep on normalizing because output
of the layer can be whatever so you
normalize it so that you have better
gradient propagation properties so you
have different kinds of normalizations
uh I'm not going to Define later today
I'm going to Define one of them
explicitly but you can do it over the
instance over the whole sample you can
do it over the batch you can do it over
the layer the are different ways of in
which you take normalizations so in
particular just imagine that in the time
independent case what you do in
normalization is that you you take the
output for instance you take the output
here of this uh particular lay and then
this is what happens right so you take
the output and you take out the mean so
you you average over different things
and these different things the where you
take the expectation gives you different
um examples of normalizations whether it
is instance Norm or batch Norm or layer
Norm so this depends on where you take
these expectations so you normalize
across different channels or you
normalize across different inputs or you
normalize across different layers so
these are the different sort of things
that you you can potentially do so you
take the mean out so you extract the
mean that takes out the trend and then
you divide by the standard deviation so
this roughly forces things between minus
one and one and of course you make it
learnable right so this is uh there are
some scale factors so the scale factors
G and H are the learnable scale factors
so that you learn how much of these
inputs and outputs are to be modulated
now in lead time conditioning what we do
is that we directly Target this
particular normalization and we simply
say that you feed in the time here so
you feed in the time here and you make
this learnable things as MLPs so in
other words this GN let me write
down GN of T could be for instance Sigma
of some W of t + B something like this
so you have some weight Factor these are
small small neural networks right so
small
MLPs and these are learnable parameters
of course you learn them along the
process so that you don't you allow the
machine learning algorithm to discover
its own normalizations so this a very
very simple trick uh remember that every
sort of machine deep learning
architecture has these kind of
normalizations and you just condition
them at time that's why these are called
conditional normalizations or time
conditional
normalizations okay so what does it mean
in Practical terms now let me try to
explain this uh through this picture
here so remember that uh all these
layers so for instance if you take this
layer these are all independent layers
right you do some convolutions you do
some nonlinearities convolutions
nonlinearities patching concatenation
and so on each of these you can put in a
Time conditioning so here you have a
time conditioning here A Time
conditioning here time conditioning here
and so on and similarly up here you have
to do a Time conditioning a Time
conditioning a Time conditioning time
conditioning time conditioning so you
have an additional uh learnable
element everywhere okay so this is a
simple way an elegant way to imprint
time across the entire neural network so
that it learns that aha at this instance
I still have to predict something I have
to do something attribute or deduce
attributes computer features related to
some sort of um some sort of time
dependent process right so this is a
very very useful trick and later on in
the numerical experiments I'm going to
illustrate how this is going to be
useful okay so you give time initially
but that is certainly not going to be
enough you give time as uh an input as a
sort of input at every layer through
this layer normaliz or through this
normalizations okay so this is going to
be the key trick by which we can put
time into the neural network is that
clear and if you have questions uh of
course the interaction in a zoom call is
much limited but you can always ask
questions through the chat box and I'll
I'll try to answer them okay if not let
us try to see so this is the at the
architecture level at the model level
what we can do in order to put time into
the into the mix in the equation but we
can also do some things at the level of
training and let me try to explain
that so there are different kinds of
training strategies that you can do let
me try to explain at least two of them
which are um which can be useful and
let's concentrate on that so first we
can do what is called one at a time
training what does it mean so in this
particular case remember that whenever
we have data it's always in the form of
these trajectories so in other words
perhaps I can write it down here that
you have trajectories so let's say your
trajectories
trajectory and this is U at
TK okay this is uh K from 1 to capital K
so this is what is given to us whenever
we have been given data we have been
given trajectories like this now I made
a very simple assumption that in all
across all the samples across all the
training samples I have access to the
solution at the same time point which is
okay when you're doing numerical
simulations which is perhaps not okay
when you are for instance having to deal
with observational data if you have
observational data then you can you can
sort of Bring It you you can also deal
deal with that you know this is not
limited to just having sampling at the
same points you can sample at different
points okay that's not going to be an
issue so what you do is in this one at a
time um training what you do is that uh
during the training you give as inputs
your initial condition which is UB bar
which is given here and you give the
times TK so you give them as and then
you get K samples per trajectory in
other words let me write down the loss
function
so the loss function L is equal to l is
now the loss function it is not related
to the differential operator right so it
is 1 /
K okay then you have the sum this is a
little K from 1 to capital K of the
output of your operator so let me call
it as s start so you have U at TK so
some Norm U at TK minus s star of TK U
Bar some Norm okay some Norm over X so
remember that in space we are assuming
that these are functions right of course
we have to discretize them further in
space because uh but in principle neural
operator is able to deal with spatial
inputs which are continuous right so you
have Reno and so on properties to take
care of that so what do I do here let me
try to explain that so I look at all
these times DK okay and so this is loss
at the sample I so this I at sample
right so l i and then of course the
overall loss is also a summation over I
I from 1 to M of um Li so there so first
of all per sample what you have to do is
you look at the solution at different
times TK you take the initial data you
output the solution you compare the
losses and then you bend them together
add the together and you sort of uh do
the optimization over all samples so as
you can see here if we have different
sampling points there is no issue right
because each of these um losses are
taken independently so you can of course
have different sampling points so this
is what is called one at a time training
so the advantage of this compared to
before is that you have K training
samples for trajectory okay and we will
see that this this can be a very
effective strategy sometimes that you
you just evaluate a different times but
this is not really taking out the full
potential of the method because the full
potential of the method is by using what
is called all to all
training so what is this all to all
training so remember that we have the
trajectory so we have the CU of TK so
the idea now and please concentrate on
this point because it's an important
point is that what we are going to do is
at the time of training we not only
going to consider what happens when you
take the solution from initial data to
is to a given time but we consider all
the intermediate times so perhaps it's
not a bad idea to draw a
picture um and try to so let me explain
that with at some so one at a
time is the following so now let me draw
the picture in the following manner so
we have uh 0 T1 T2 T3 like this sub to
DK d k + 1 up to Capital DK so imagine
that at each of these points you have
been given a function right because
that's that's what we have not not a
single vector or a single value but a
whole function then uh what do we have
in one at a time training is that uh you
first give the initial initial value
here so this was U Bar U Bar and then
you give so you you compute the solution
at this time so you do this then you you
compute the solution at this time then
you compute the solution at this time
compute the solution at this time and so
on right so these are the k k versions
of the trajectory K applications of your
operator and then you sum them up the
way I've just described them so that is
one at a time s but what we want to do
is something radically more more sort of
not complicated but extensive and this
is all all to all what does that mean so
all to all roughly speaking is along the
following
lines okay so let me draw the picture
here so again you have zero you have T1
you have T2 TK TK + 1 blah blah blah
right all the intermediate times are
given so now in addition to going from
so imagine that from zero in principle
the solution operator can take you to T1
it can take you to T2 it can take you to
D3 D4 and so on just like we did before
right but we we also know that this is a
semigroup the solution of a Time
dependent PD is a semigroup so in
principle if I'm sitting at T1 okay I
can go to T2 by just taking T1 minus T2
delta T as my time increment right but I
can also go from T1 to T3 by having two
times delta T as the time increment I
can go from T1 to T4 I can go from T1 to
T5 all of this is possible I can start
at T1 and then go to T5 to T6 to t7 all
of this is possible similarly I can sit
at TK I can't go back in time right
there is causality so time always has an
arrow you always go forward in time you
cannot go back except if the problem is
reversible and this we don't know a
priority whether the PD is reversible or
not but just imagine that you are at TK
so you can't go back but you can go to
TK +
1 you can go to TK + 1 with Delta TK
increment you can go to TK + 2 TK + 3 so
on and finally up to T capital K so all
this is possible so essentially from the
initial conditions you can go to all the
time Steps From The First Time step you
can go to the remaining K minus one time
steps for the second time step you can
put the remaining K minus 2 time steps
and so on and so forth so we are going
to exploit this because this data is
already given to us it is it is very
much there so this is a smart idea that
uh we came up with uh because uh this
has not been considered in the
literature so essentially what you can
do is that probably I have written down
this here exactly so if you start at a
point uh
TI you can go to any J which is greater
than I okay so in other words if you
start at TK you can go to TK + 1 TK + 2
TK + three and so on you of course have
to provide the lead times because that's
the amount of time that it takes for the
solution to evolve and then you give the
value of the solution there right so
what is the advantage of this strategy
first of all the data is there right
whenever you have been given a
trajectory you have been given all these
data points they they're available to
you you don't you don't have to Scamper
for the data but the advantage is now we
have lot more data right because
remember that then from the first point
from this point we have access to K data
then K minus plus K minus one data K
minus 2 data points and so on till one
and this we know is that it's k k + 1 by
2 right so instead of having um linear
the the the data content in the
trajectory earlier was just linear so
you had K training samples per
trajectory now you have K Square
training time samples per trajectory
right so it's a dramatic augmentation of
your data and you do this for free in
the sense that this data is already
there right so the advantage of this all
to all training is to be able to
Leverage this uh semigroup this
causality property of the solution
operator okay so that whenever you have
been during training what we are going
to do is that we are going to take all
these pairs uh images or pictures or
whatever you have we're going to take
all these pairs and then we are going to
be able to access we going to use them
for the training so what is going to be
the loss function now this is
interesting have it requires a
expression so
the loss
function again this is for the ith
trajectory because you also have to sum
over the trajectories right so I
trajectory so use sum
over okay perhaps L maybe l so you do
the following okay so you take um U at
DJ okay minus s star so this is your
neural operator which takes into account
TJ minus
TI of U at TI the data is given to you
so you generate the data and then you do
the norm here over some function Space X
and this is i j from 1 to capital k i
less than J okay so this is the trick so
now what you can do is that you can take
all these intermediate points you you
use your neural operator so in other
words they give the neural operator the
time T1 and ask it to generate the
solution at time T2 and then compare
using this method similarly you take it
at TK and ask it to compare it at TK + 5
and then you bin it together compute the
loss function and then of course overall
you have to sum over all the
trajectories right so in addition to
this you also have the sum over all the
trajectories so the amount of data is
quad quadratic in the number of time
steps per trajectory trory and it's also
Quadra not quadratic of course it's
linear in the number of trajectories so
let us imagine that we have a th000
trajectories which is nothing nothing
exceptional and we have let's say 20
time steps uh 20 saves that we have then
per uh trajectory we have 210 right
because yeah 210 uh samples and then in
addition we also have a th000
trajectories so we have 210,000
trajectories so this allows us to
augment our data seriously and we need
all this data you'll see later on that
this data is very very important okay so
this is the basic principle behind this
all to all training is this clear this
is sort of it requires a little bit of
concentration and it requires a little
bit of thinking about how we are
inputting the data how we are outputting
the data and so on are there any
questions any first questions on this on
this approach you can either unmute
yourself or you can ask through the chat
box no okay think about it and if there
are any questions you can hopefully I'm
better on Friday and uh I can come to
class and then you can you can ask me
the questions now this is what happens
at the level of training that you take
into account this additional data this
um let's say quadratic in the number of
saves quadratic in the number of time
steps per trajectory and so remember
that this is a complete contrast to what
we had in the last lecture so in the
last lecture we were just using the fact
that per per sample or per trajectory we
have exactly one sample because we are
simply using endpoint evaluations now we
have increased it by a factor of K squ
which is a lot more right so instead of
a th000 samples we will have 210,000
samples and this is uh this is an
important Point okay there is there is a
subtle point that I'm going to mention
in a second so what about the inference
at the time of inference what do we do
the inference can be the way it has been
set up that it can be direct or it can
be Auto regressive so let me try to
explain this again maybe I have have an
additional
page because it's
important damn
it I didn't want that did
I okay I wanted a blank page
no isn't this the one yeah so what is uh
what what happens the level of inference
so let's try to take this so have
inference
so now you have this trained operator s
star and what can it take it can take T
and it can take q and it can produce
what it wants to produce now your task
is let's say that you are again let me
draw a
picture so you are starting at t equal
to Z and let's say that all that you are
interested is that the solution at later
time t equal to T okay you train the way
you want to train but what you want to
infer is just a solution at a final time
T now there are different ways in which
this can be done the first thing that we
can do is that you can do a direct
evaluation direct influence what do I
mean by
that so simply take s so this is ubar so
simply take this okay it has been
trained but now at the level of
inference it just takes this value and
it infers so that is direct and this
this can be effective this is very cheap
because it's only one evaluation of the
neural operator
but of course you can say well we have
trained all to all we have information
about intermediate time points why don't
we use that during inference you can so
in that context what you can do is you
can
choose so this is auto regressive let's
write it down Auto regressive
inference so what you can do is you can
start by doing one at one step Auto
regressive rollouts right so what does
that mean that you can go to you can
apply a star to T1 and then U Bar so you
go from here to here no problems then
you apply again uh so you take this as
the input and take T2 minus T1 apply
your operator so that's the next roll
out do here then you apply your operator
once more T3 minus T2 and you get the
drift right so you you can do this one
step at a time one step at a
time this is one one possibility that
it's a one one one autor regressive roll
up but remember that the way my neural
operator time dependent neural operator
is set up I don't have to do this I can
do any combination in other words let me
try to explain that let's use another
color red and I say that in the first
step I go three steps I go here so in
other words my operator would be let's
say s star of T3
three T3 U okay for some reason I say
okay I can go all the way I can jump
three steps and in the next step I can
say I want to jump five steps or four
steps or something like that so I have
my my operator can output any solution
right so then what I do is I take
T t7 minus T3 4 so it jumps four steps
and then it goes to a star and so on and
so forth right so you of course have to
take take finitely many steps so that
you reach capital T A steps but so you
can do any of these choices now so we
have the flexibility so what and this is
at the level of inference so we just
have to check for ourselves of course
there's a price that we pay right
because in terms of the cost there are
two things here cost and accuracy so in
terms of the cost it is quite
straightforward uh to see that the
direct evaluation is the cheapest
because I have to do one computation of
the neural operator but but in and this
is the most expensive auto regressive is
the most expensive uh Auto regressive in
the sense that all these steps right
because that will have to do K
evaluations of the operator and anything
in between is between one and K I can do
three I can do six depending on what I
want to do but the accuracy is going to
be very very different right because it
could be that for a particular problem
and we will see examples of that that
direct since you have to go far out you
are going to make more errors because it
has to learn something much more
complicated Auto regressive is simpler
because you just have to predict the
next time step the next time step and so
on but your error can accumulate so
often times what happens is that
something in between is the optimal
strategy as you will see in some of the
numerical experiments so this is a
choice that is left to the user by doing
this kind of a training and by setting
things up in uh in in this uh setup that
I just explained what we have is that we
have multiple possibilities for auto
regressive rollouts and in particular we
can predict at any time because we can
just give the lead time and we can
predict so in principle we have a
continuous time prediction and this is
often what is lacking because people can
only make discrete time predictions as I
explained in the last lecture but we can
make uh continuous time predictions in
particular to what are called out of
distribution times so what do I mean by
that these are times that have not been
seen during the training process and
I'll I'll give you examples okay so good
so we have a do training strategy which
sort of assimilates or accumulates data
in a nice Manner and inference is based
on it gives you a lot of flexibility at
the time of inference and it allows us
to learn the entire operator okay now
let us try to see how how this works in
practice okay I'll delete some of this
so why do I have this because I wanted
to show you a movie here so all the
results that I'm going to show today are
based on the Sher l so let me see if I
can I
can I should have
no yeah exactly so this is this is a
final time I wanted to show at earlier
time so again let me show you what it is
so this is the x velocity of course now
I can't annotate but on top is the x
velocity on bottom is the Y velocity and
this is a movie so this is what we are
interested
in so okay so it plays so you start with
something and then the solution looks
particularly concentrate on the Y
velocity and see how much the solution
has changed right I should have slowed
down the movie now I realize that the
movie should be slowed down but you see
that uh there is a lot of complex
phenomena that is happening and there's
a big change in terms of time so you
start from t equal to Z and you go to
tal to 1 I think in this particular case
Okay so let's see what are the results
uh so this was the sh a the first thing
that you do is to compute error versus
time okay so there are two plots here
and the this plot is um this is uh
actual error this is the number of
training trajectories perhaps what is
more interesting is this is a log log
plot as you can see this is Log and
log or semi log at least so we have this
uh so we get a particular Trend the
important thing here is a number of
training trajectories is what is being
used so we go all the way from 256
training trajectories to
8,192 training trajectories and here we
are just doing a direct evaluation means
this is the the training is one at a
time training not all to all one at a
time so in practice if you have 256
trajectories I don't remember I think
there are like 10 saves or 10 snapshots
here so it is 2560 2560 time steps the
important thing that two things here
first of all as you this is
CNO time condition CNO the first thing
as you can see is that as the number of
as the amount of data increases the
error goes down in a very predictable
manner the rate is 0.33 means a very
very predictable completely nice scaling
and what is very very important here is
that uh it's true for every time so
whether I want to evaluate at time tal
to 0.2 or all the way up to tal to 1
I I get the same kind of a
scaling what differs are the constants
okay so as you can see that as you go
forward in time so of course from 0 to
0.2 it's easier to predict and the error
is going to be smaller so for instance
if I take ,24 trajectories it is 1%
error for the first uh for 0.2 and it is
going to be two little less than 2%
error for uh for the 0. 4 it is going to
be something like 3% error for 0.5 uh
0.6 for 0.8 it is going to be a little
4% error and then it is going to be
something like 6% error so if you if you
look here the error is going to increase
somehow linearly right it's not going
exponentially it is going to increase
linearly so this tells you that this
strategy works you are able to scale
with respect to the amount of training
data the error of course has to grow
because it's harder to learn what
happens at T Al to one then from the
initial data then is to learn at t equal
to Zer and here the inference is direct
so this is one at a time training
inference is direct just a base
configuration okay so it it works as as
expected and what is also interesting is
that now we are able to we are able to
sort of evaluate at times that have not
been seen before so for instance you you
train that so these were the data points
that were given 0.2 0 .4
0.6
0.8 uh and
1.0 but in between also we were able to
train it very nicely in the beginning
there's a lot of error of course because
remember that there's a very sharp
transition particularly in the Y
velocity but other than that uh even
though 0.5 was never seen during the
training it is able to predict the
solution at 0.5 the same with 0.7 it was
never seen in during the training it's
able to predict that and so on and so
forth so does it's it's a continuous
prediction in time not just a discrete
prediction okay so then uh these are the
different tring strategy so no this is a
different inference strategies so
remember that the simplest is of course
direct as as expected uh it gave you
whatever results that it gave you so
this is inference
strategies so this is what I explained
just before I went into the numerical
results section right so I explained uh
the different kinds of inference
strategies whether we do direct whether
we do auto regressive and what kind of
Auto regressive rollups we can
do okay so here as you can see direct uh
was not as efficient as so Auto
regressive this is uh one step roll out
so 10 10 * 1 means so we we want to
predict the solution in 10 saves not 10
time stes but 10 snapshots so what we do
is that we first pute from 0 to one 1 1
to 2 2 to 4 2 to 3 and so on from 9 to
10 so already you can see that the
Orange is better than the better than
this one of course this is more
expensive but perhaps the Orange is more
expensive than blue but perhaps uh the
inference costs are not not considered
that seriously and then as I said we can
go different different ways it has
slightly better scaling properties
though So eventually maybe it will catch
up but as you can see we have different
kinds of uh strategies that we can take
so we can take two jumps right we can go
from 0 to five then 5 to 10 this gives
you the answer here not not as good but
uh then as you can see the two which are
better are somehow intermediate for
instance uh this one the green one it
takes one time step in the beginning and
this is take into account that there's a
fast transition in the solution things
happen much more quickly in the
beginning and then the heris stic is
that they happen more slowly so it goes
one time step and then three to four
then three more to seven and then three
more to 10 and this gives you the best
results and the training is exactly the
same it's the same neural operator it's
just by doing a slightly different form
of inference you can see that you can
bring down the solution quite a bit for
instance let's um let's look at let's
look at this one so this is 1,24
trajectories okay so somewhere here is
the solution I guess and this is the
Corr responding one here the direct
evaluation and as you can see so this
was like I don't know 6% and this one is
more like less than 2% even so by factor
of three you bring down the error simply
by using a different heuristic where you
you have some knowledge of the solution
and you use that to have this heuristic
evaluation okay similarly another
strategy that one could use was to go
five times in the beginning and then two
and three and that also seemed to be
effective this I have no no humanistic
explanation I I can understand why the
green is better than the orange and the
blue but I don't have any reasons to
understand why the why the red is uh
better than the other things but this is
how it is so the idea is to tell you
that there is there is a variety there
is a choice that you can do at the level
of infuence okay and then I want to go
for the break by talking about different
training strategies so these are
training okay so remember that uh so T1
is one at a
time and T2 is all to
all and as you can see uh there are
different inference strategies so T1 and
T2 are represented here as you can see
that there is a consistent gain because
you simply have more data so with the
all to all you you get uh you get a big
gain or not a big gain but a gain
nevertheless right as you can see for
every the same number of training
trajectories one is consistently better
than the other and if you sort of couple
this together with the not regressive
roll out this is 442 then you can see
very clearly that this is a there is a
there is a there is a significant gain
so for instance with uh 248 trajectories
you can go down from about uh 5% to 2
and a half% or something like that right
so this this really pays off and of
course the training is more expensive
now because you're taking into account
more data points so the training is
going to be more expensive but this is
the strategy that we are going to
leverage from now onwards that we're
going to train all to all and in terms
of inference we can either do direct or
we can do auto regressive depending on
the context that we are okay so this is
uh what I wanted to say with respect to
time dependent operators just to
summarize just by putting in time
conditioning into the architecture we
have been able to predict the solution
not just that any point in space that
was the whole point about Reno and
neural operators but at any point in
time we have been able to leverage the
fact that it's a Time dependent problem
there is causality and so on in order to
be able to predict in order to be able
to use more training data and we also
been able to leverage that to have
inventive autor regressive roll outs
okay so with that I stop here and let's
meet at 10 past uh 12 minutes break and
then from there we we change gears a
little bit and we try to solve some of
the other problems that we saw with
neural operators okay see you in a see
you in a
bit hello are people
back yeah so I can only see David but
okay let's anyway start hopefully people
will be back soon so during the break
there was a nice question by Luca Luca
Gator so Luca asked is all to all
training strategy and autor regressive
inference technique specific to cnos or
can it be extended to Any Time dependent
neural operator so yes uh it's it is
nothing to do with the spatial structure
of the neural operator any all this is
true for any neural operator because uh
you know all neural operators whether
it's fno CNO Depon net and so on these
all use different kinds of normalization
layers and you just put time into those
normalization layers exactly in the
method that I described so this strategy
and the all to all is at the level of
data and the loss function so it has
nothing to do with the specifics of the
neural operator that that that you are
training so this is uh going to be as
generic as you get also do we see
similar eror scaling as we saw in the
sheer layer benchmarks uh yes in all
problems we have evidence of this kind
of a scaling of course the exponents are
going going to be the constants this the
rates are going to be very different the
constants are going to be very different
and a problem specific but the
qualitative picture is exactly the same
but there is always consistent scaling
and what I showed in the last slide is
absolutely HS okay so with that uh
answer to that question which was a very
relevant one let me move to the next uh
topic essentially and let me start by
reminding you some of the issues that we
started off with right so we had these
three issues that we identified data on
non-uniform grids
um I gave you some ideas but I don't
know if you'll have time to address them
time dependent problems is something
that we addressed now and the last point
is this uh concept of scaling with data
means how much of data is enough data
right and let's start with that so in
some sense uh the fact what I presented
here is a different ways in which we are
able to add data to scale better with
data and so on but this is still the the
key issue you know that the key is going
to be the scaling and we know that
whether we take the time dependent
version or not we have very consistent
scaling rules uh so this was again the
sh a but just uh without the time
dependent version just end time
prediction and you saw that there were
these different rates here also you saw
that there were different rates uh where
was the picture that HED different rates
so the question that comes in is uh
automatically can we improve the rates
okay
so the key somehow is indeed scaling so
the question is so then given that we
have this context this background the
correct model or the model that we need
to use is the one that scales the best
right me in the sense that if you
provide it enough data it should have
the best performance in some in some
sense and this is what has been
understood now for the last 2 three
years in the in the machine Learning
Community not not just for scientific
machine learning machine learning for
scientific problems but machine learning
for vision for text and so on and so
forth and this idea came essentially
from language modeling because uh text
NLP whatever you call it NLP natural
language processing where people realize
that the key to everything is scaling
and this happened around 2020 2021 so
there's a very influential paper of
Jared Kaplan at all at that time at AI
these people moved to anthropic now but
this was around 2020 and they discovered
something which is interesting and
phenomenal and that is uh what I'm
showing you here so this was not about
not about the kind of problems that we
dealing with it's about just language
it's about uh modeling natural languages
right and the idea of kapan at all was
the following that they just took um so
you know in language is also somehow a
recurrent task so let's say say that
lstms uh rnns were sort of state of the
art in let's say 2017 2018 and so on and
the point is so these are the number of
uh this is the loss and this is uh how
things scal right with respect to model
size with respect to data and so on and
they observed that lstms scaled but they
scaled very slowly and they were
saturated very very quickly and the
architecture that managed to sort of
beat this was Transformers
okay so essentially from this uh capit n
all paper so this is Cap N all this you
know this all that they did is that they
took a bunch of models and they took a
bunch of tasks and they studied how
things change when you increase model
size and how you when you increase the
amount of data and these people became
famous uh Jared Kaplan recently was even
profiled in New York Times you know
so so it's out of so what are the
observations so essentially what they
did is for natural language they try to
study
scaling with respect to
data with respect to model
sici and the somehow data and model size
together they constitute
compute all right because during
training now we are not even talking
about inference but during training you
have to Loop over all the available data
so you know you you do through batches
and in each batch you have to Loop over
some set of the data then the next batch
you Loop over another set of the data
and so on and so forth so somehow the
comput is roughly the product it's not
exactly and uh it's roughly the product
of data versus model size and the
discovery was that compared to all
architectures so there was first of all
there was consistent scaling there's no
reason for it you know there's always
consistent scaling the exponents of
course the rates the constants they
change uh in different uh
in different settings there's no
universality in terms of the rate but
the quantitative feature is exactly the
same so the idea is that this problem
will be solved in some sense if we if we
take large enough models with large
enough data right so that's uh and this
is the beginning of llms the beginning
of large Vision models and so on and so
forth people understood that they have
to scale up their models and as you saw
in my previous lecture also in the
lecture before uh first hour of today's
lecture
we observe similar kind of scaling rules
with what we are doing right so that
realization has also caught on to us but
let's say 3 4 years later so there is
consistent scaling and the most
important thing is that among all these
uh architectures at least for language
modeling Transformers they really shine
in terms of uh they have scale
better so this was sort of compared to
other architectures right so
Transformers are going to scale better
if you have more data you have better
model size they're able to scale they're
able to use the information the compute
better right so this kind of
considerations which are there in
language modeling coupled with the
observations that we saw in the last
couple of lectures that there is this
consistent scaling that inspires us to
move towards Transformers okay so this
is just a representation of Transformers
and uh today and in the next lecture
potentially in the lecture next week
also to some extent I'm going to give
you at least a beginning and input a
feel for what what Transformers can do
in this in this particular World okay
and it can't be arbitrary Transformers
because you saw that with this gin
Transformer it didn't really skap right
so what's what's the principle here so
we change Gees so the basis of
Transformers is something called
attention uh many of you might have at
least read it in the media that uh in
Transformers are all based on a
mechanism on a on a mathematical object
called attention and this came in in
2017 with this very influential paper
from Google uh vaswani at all which told
us that okay there is a different way of
processing inputs and outputs of neural
networks and let me explain it in terms
of discrete uh objects and later on I'm
also going to explain it in terms of
functions because everything that is
that can be done at a discrete level can
be sort of um lifted up to the level of
functions so what is the principle of
attention so first of all let's imagine
that uh so the point is we think in
terms of of sequences and uh attention
or Transformers they were introduced for
sequence modeling but we can convert our
problems uh to a sequence modeling
problem very easily so think of your
input in terms of a input
sequence so this is a
sequence think of a onedimensional
function perhaps this the easiest to
understand okay and what is the input so
the input is going to be a vector
v okay and so this is V1 V2 all the way
up to V capital K so think of
discretization of a onedimensional
function right and each of this is a
vector of n Dimensions or n features so
you have for instance a onedimensional
vector function discretized the
different points in space it's a very
very simple understanding so what
convolutions would do this is what we
have looked at so far in CNO and
fno I'm not she seeing any shared screen
someone is complaining that
uh people can see the screen right uh
yeah it seems that everyone can see the
screen okay can see it you can see it
right uh then the whole lecture would
have been redundant okay just check it
for yourself what's what's the situation
so remember now the pay attention to
this pay attention to attention so what
you do in CNO or fno is you do
convolutions so what what would have
been convolutions is you take a kernel
of a fixed size and then you apply the
kernel to Bunches of these points right
first to the first three points next to
the next three points next to the next
three points and so on but the self
attention is completely different from
that so what you do here is that you are
not going to sort of scroll through
you're not going to plow through the
entire sequence by using discrete blocks
rather you're going to study the
cumulative effect of each of these uh
features these are sometimes called
tokens okay in from language modeling
these are called tokens so each of these
features so VK is the K token because it
came from language modeling but think of
it as the value at a certain point right
so what we're going to do is we're going
to define a matrix in this case or a
function in this case not a matrix
valued function such that uh the
following mechanism works and maybe the
best is to explain what goes on uh
perhaps I I need to blank yeah perhaps I
need to explain it on on a piece of
paper so remember what we are doing now
so we have uh so these are your tokens
so you have V1 V2 V3 V4 and so on V5 V6
so on so what you do now is that you're
going to study the cumulative effect of
all of them together so in other words
you can see unlike a convolution you're
going to see what is the effect of V1 to
V2 V1 to V3 V1 to V4 V1 to V5 V2 just
like all to all right V2 to V3 V2 to V4
V2 to V5 you going to study these
correlations in some sense and how do
you study these correlations there is a
particular method there's a particular
sort of throughput through which you
study so what you do is that now now we
have to be a bit careful about defining
different things
here okay so the first thing that we are
going to do is that we are going to fix
uh so this is the output of the
attention function uh a of V so we are
going to look at the result of this
attention at the kth point so this is
going to be your UK and there are
several elements to it so first element
is that we are going to sum over the
contributions that are made by all the
points to this point okay the
information that is the Cor ations the
information that is carried over from
all the points to this point so we are
going to attend to this point from all
the other points that's why there's a
sum over all the other tokens okay so
the information it's not like a
convolution because in a convolution
only the information from the nearby
points is going to be taken into account
here on the other hand the information
from all the points is going to be taken
into account okay this is an important
important uh issue to mention here and
how is this taken into account so first
of all you take there are three objects
here three
matrices uh query key and value okay
these are again nomenclature from
natural language processing but why
these things come about is not important
to our context we just have to remember
that these are matrices these are
matrices of a certain size they don't
depend on the to token itself so
remember the size of all these matrices
is fixed so it is uh so they have um n
columns and they have M rows so what is
n n is your feature Dimension remember
that each of these tokens has n features
right so that's your feature Dimension
and M is what is called um an embedding
Dimension or an attention Dimension or
whatever key query value Dimension so
this is a sort of an internal
representation Dimension okay so for
instance n can be 10 and M can be 20
mean this is a hyper parameter that
you're going to choose it is independent
of the number of tokens and this is the
most important thing so for all the
tokens so you're going to have the same
same objects that are going to come in
so you're going to compute these are
learnable matrices so at each point uh
so remember that I'm going to update uh
the value or update the input at this
particular Point K so what I'm going to
do is that I'm going to Loop over I'm
going to sum over all the points V1 V2
all the way up to V capital K and what I
do is that at each of these points I
compute the value so this is a matrix
Vector multiply each of these points so
at V1 I compute the value V of V1 V of
V2 and so
on and each of these points I compute
the key the same same principle here K
of VJ I compute the key and then comes
the interesting part of attension so so
far so good but as you can see that here
I don't put a k i compute the query so
essentially what you do again coming
back to the picture here is that at all
these points so I have um I compute
uh V of V1 V of V2 all the way of V of
this is very
bad okay so V of V capital K similarly
compute the keys here K of V1 K of V2 K
of capital VK but I also compute the
queries so Q of V1 Q of
V2 and so on Q of V
now what I'm going to do is that I fix
the J entry so I have K of PJ and then I
do a all to one broadcast okay so in
other words I compute this in a product
Q of V1 K of VJ Q of V2 K of
VJ uh and this is your fixed J so now
when you move j you can see that there
is this quadratic multiplication Q of VK
Q of VJ so what we're going to do is
that at each point so there are two
Loops here right so first in the outer
loop you're going to fix my J and you're
going to sum over J and then there is an
inner loop here in the Inner Loop what
you're going to do is that you're going
to compute the query at all the points
uh all the other points here so in other
words I could have I'm interested in
Computing here I fix this point and I do
all the loops and then I compute all
these values and then what I do is that
I do a soft Max so all of you might have
seen soft Max softmax is a way in which
I can convert a vector into a vector
vector of arbitrary entries into a
vector of probabilities simply by taking
a weighted exponential so in other words
what am I doing here so what I'm doing
here essentially is that uh so there are
two Loops as I said so in the perhaps I
add
another I add another blank page so
there are two loops oops uh as I said so
maybe I put
this okay so at the end of the day I'm
interested in Computing the value at
this point let's let's call it as K okay
little K and what I do in the first in
the outer loop is I look at all the
values
so okay something like this
so in Outer Loop I'm going to fix let's
use another color let's say J so I'm
going to fix this J and I'm going to
sort of sum over all of these JS okay
then there's another third Loop which is
the inner loop here which is given
by so now I have fixed
J is the same uh
Vector something like this right
something like this now I fixed J and
then what I'm going to Loop over is all
these points so I compute the queries
and I this kind of a
broadcast similarly here here so
essentially what you do is that this uh
guy here this operation here is the key
point of attention this is a scaled dot
product you'll see in the next lecture
that we can take another function or
different other functions is a scale do
product what it tells us is the effect
on uh the value on the token the JS
token from the ks token relative effect
right because we are taking sort of a
soft Max over all the possible values so
we are taking the relative effect okay
so what what is the computation then the
computation is that you in order to find
the value here I'm going to so I'm going
to sum over all these
points okay especially the jth point so
this tells you the relative contribution
of each of the surrounding tokens
including the token itself right so
there is also self attention including
the token itself from all the it
receives information from all the other
tokens but the information that it
receives from all the other tokens also
involves a further Loop where this
information is weighted by the relative
contributions of each token right so
this is why so you can see that there
are K entry K elements K operations here
and K operations here so there's this
entire mechanism is going to be
quadratic okay okay so when I show you
the functional version of it it's
probably going to be clearer soft Max is
just one way of so this is telling you
the weighted average of the information
so what is attention attention tells you
that you know to make some update at
this point how do I take into account
accumulate information from other points
in a smart man so humanistically it is
not a very very difficult concept at all
okay and then finally all this gives you
matrices which are uh m cross n so you
have to come back to n * n Matrix so
then you have an output Matrix which is
given here okay so it's all based on
some very simple Matrix operations it is
independent of the number of tokens so
you can take whatever tokens you want
because this this learnable matrices q k
w and V these are um these are arbitrary
so there is no there is no particular
sort of structure to them in the sense
that these are only depending on the
feature Dimension and on this embedding
Dimension M and uh you should also think
about why this is permutation invariant
because there is no no ordering here so
I can I can just jumble these things
together and I will get back the same
value okay perhaps this will become
clearer when I look at it from a
function perspective so at this level at
the vector level is where you implement
things so the you have to compute
essentially these two different Loops
where you compute this squarey key and
value vectors and you do a soft Max and
you can understand it very well from
okay perhaps I explain this here as a
neural operator uh maybe it falls better
in our in our Y St
okay so again the same principle so your
input now is a function it could be in
arbitrary Dimensions but uh let's say
for Simplicity I'm in one dimension uh
things are things are simpler then the
geometry is exactly the same and then
what is attention attention can be
thought of in this terms okay it looks
ugly but that is what it
is so what am I doing so now let's think
in terms of functions uh so I have a
function here which has been given its
different values at different points so
as you can see that there are two Loops
or two sums or in this case they get
converted into two integrals you have an
outer integral which is in y so these
are all the other points
so uh how do I do this
maybe again I
add black paper so let's let's for
Simplicity do it like this so have 0 to
one let's say and you have fixed number
of points that you have discretized in
at each of these points you have
um let's take three of these right
because okay let's uh I don't know how
to copy it because I think that is a
function by which I can copy this
thing takes me longer to copy than to
write okay so this is your input V right
so your input is here so these are
called
VK so this is XK VK is sitting here so
in the F there are two integrals so
first is outer integral the outer
integral is taken over y so the effect
over Y is uh computed so in other words
what I'm going to do is to integrate
here so which means that I take all
these guys and evaluate them at this
point okay and then in addition I have
this inner integral so this is where the
soft Max comes in the soft Max has just
been Rewritten in this form so at each
point Y so I'm integrating over Y at
each point y i compute the value I
compute the key okay but I also have to
compute the key I also compute the key
here but I compute the query at every
other point Z so this is the second
integral so this is the integral over y
this is the integral over Z okay so I
have to compute the key uh the query
sorry Q at all these points and I fix y
here so I have to broadcast up to here
so there are these two Loops that are
that are there okay so as you can see
that this is a weighted sum of um or
weighted integral there is an inner
integral that gives you the weighting
and there's an outer integral which
provides you the sum overall okay and
then W is also some fixed Matrix all the
while this Q K and W and V these are
sort of fixed matrices so this is sort
of a
functional um so given a function ATT
tension can be interpreted as operating
on functions rather than as vectors
means the way to link them is to Simply
take a uniform grid and pass to the
Limit and this is indeed what you're
going to derive okay in other words if
you think of it so what happens is that
uh in terms of what operators so this is
operator attention so you can think of
it as a kernel okay so this is an
integral so you can think of it as a
kernel but now the kernel is going to be
nonlinear okay so this is a kernel K
which takes values at X and Y as you can
see but the kernel itself is nonlinear
the kernel is here so this is capital K
let me drink some water
okay so the kernel itself is nonlinear
and this is going to be the big
difference that we had before because if
you think of fno CNO and so on and so
forth Al so there're also these were
kernel integral operators remember that
we had changed the Matrix Vector
multipliers into kernel integral
operators especially with this
translation invariant kernels that's why
these were
convolutions but this was linear okay
now what we do is that we do something
which is nonlinear so this is sort of
the strength of this method in some
sense that your kernel is also being
trained based not just on the on it's
also being trained not just the kernel
Dimensions but the kernel uh structure
but also the kernel itself is being
trained depending on this nonlinear data
points okay so this is sort of the
essentially if you want to think of
attention itself you can think in terms
of this particular integral so what does
it do it takes relative contributions so
there's a kernel so this guy here is a
kernel and what the kernel does is that
it provides data dependent relative
contributions to the point Y or to the
value of the point Y okay so of course
it's a it's in that sense a very very
powerful method because now what you're
doing is that you have a kernel which
takes into account the data that you are
giving and it provides you relative
information or relative weight okay so
you expect this to be a powerful method
from that perspective because you are
you're getting information from all the
points in a data dependent manner rather
than in a fixed sort of a fixed manner
like you do so first of all compared to
convolutions you don't have any locality
anymore right convolutions are locality
this is much more Global in nature and
second it is nonlinear it is sort of
data dependent in nature so hopefully
this is a good thing of course there's a
price that we are going to pay which I'm
going to talk about in a second uh so
this is at the level of the continuous
uh function at the level of the discrete
function uh at which we implement this
is the this is the formula okay so of
course this is a new new object so think
about it and I think maybe in the next
tutorial uh they are going to introduce
some Vision Transformers and they're
going to walk you through how this is
done in practice are there any questions
so far this is a completely new concept
so if you have any questions feel free
to ask so that uh I can also see for
myself whether you have understood or
not right because otherwise I don't see
your faces so it's impossible for me to
are there any
questions okay if not uh please feel
free to ask in the next lecture so that
uh by that time you have seen these
objects and then you have understood so
again I repeat uh this is uh you are
essentially doing a kernel operation
just like in convolution except that
your colel is global and it takes into
account every other point point in the
domain but now you take into account uh
you do this in a data dependent way so
the waiting is based on the actual
values of the data of course in some
latent spaces because you're learning
representations so this is the one of
the ways in which you can think of
attention usually people don't have it
in textbooks they they operate at this
level not at this level right but this
is where we from operator learning can
understand this so Transformer is very
much a neural operator whether it's a
Reno or not is a is a different question
but at the moment it is it's a it's it's
certainly a neural operator in the sense
that it takes functions as inputs and it
turns out functions as outputs of course
there are many things that you can do uh
which are done in practice and let me
just walk you through them the first
thing is you can do what is called
multi-ad okay so now a single head would
have been just this
operation but people are not just
content with that they say aha there's
no reason why there should be only one
route in which this information is being
uh passed it can be passed in different
ways so they introduce multihead so
multi-ad is essentially now you can see
that for each head so H is the
head again the notation comes from
natural language processing but it's a
it's a very simple sort of sum over
different uh groups essentially so now
the value uh query and key these things
are um dependent on the number of the on
the head dimension on the head and then
you sum over each head okay so that's
that's all that is happening so instead
of having a single way in which uh
attention is being done what you do is
that you have multiple ways in which you
put
attention and then you accumulate them
all together okay so this is the
generalization and this can be seen of
course from an operator perspective so
from an operator perspective all that
you have to do is to add uh some H
dependence and take a sum this is not an
integral you just uh you just take a sum
so multiple heads is just multiple ways
in which you you take into account this
relative information and in practice
people have to take multiple heads okay
so typically I think in the large
language models they take anything
between 10 and 20 30 heads there a diff
there is a easy way in which you can
scale up your compute so and there is a
intuitive reason why this will be better
because you have multiple routes
multiple channels through which
information can be processed so that's
the first uh thing that you can do uh
the second thing that you can do is that
attention is not uh not that easy there
are many other so first so this is what
is typically called a Transformer
block it has many different ingredients
so this is what I have already shown you
what is multi- header tension but there
are also different normalizations skip
connections uh feed forward networks
normalizations skip connections and so
on let me try to explain that uh in the
next slide so there's a very important
point and it again comes back to the
first hour of today's lecture which is
about normalization me remember that all
the time we want the inputs to each
block to be roughly between minus and
one and one to be scaled right so for
Transformers uh almost always the right
kind of normalization is layer
normalization so what is layer
normalization so lay Norm is uh and I
interpret it as a function because we
can we can view things in terms of
functions so you have been given some
input features um n dimensional input
features so it's a mapping between n
dimensional vector and N dimensional
Vector all that it does is that you have
some learned uh scale parameters Alpha
and beta so this is a pointwise
pointwise
product pointwise
product so you take out the mean and you
divide by the standard deviation okay
and the mean and the standard Dev ation
are simply over the features over the
simp over the channels okay so in other
words if you think of an attention layer
whatever the output of the attenion
layer is coming coming out whatever the
output is coming out all that you do is
that you so this has different input
features again it's independent of the
tokens that you are getting right so for
every token you do this normalization by
itself so you just average over the
channels okay and it is a very simple
operator all that you do is that it's
it's independent and different tokens
are independent so of course as a
function of space you take a vector VX
and you just play normalize it so this
is layer normalization what it provides
is that uh information across different
channels is normalized across tokens it
can still be different so this is uh
this is this is a very very simple
operation and it is almost universally
used in uh Transformers right so when we
want to use our neural operators what we
do is that we will make this Alpha and
beta time depend so Alpha of t and beta
of T and you can imagine that these are
always initialized Alpha is initialized
around one and beta is initialized
around zero during TR so that is one
thing and then we need some MLPs we need
some feed forward and again I will give
you an operator interpretation so you
have your feature input feature input
Vector is V which is in
RN and then all that you do is the
pointwise now this is totally pointwise
you take this RN dimensional Vector you
multiply with d * n Matrix so just like
you do with an MLP you add a bias Vector
which is uh D dimensional and then what
you end up and then you have another one
to normalize so this is n crd so these
are very very local operation so for
every token you have this MLP and this
is pointwise you do it across all the
tokens and you share the weights of
course so this is some featurization
across each of these across each of
these domains so it's a very straight
forward operation and then we have uh
everything that we need so we have this
operator Transformer block which is
which is given here so this is sequence
of operations so you start with your
input function V okay this is for
instance on a grid then the first thing
that you do is that you use multi-head
self attention
MSA so you start with V this will give
you your uar uh we have interpreted this
as an operator so you attend to the Val
at different points then you do a
normalization l Norm first you add of
course you have a skip connection so you
take you take V you have U Bar and then
you do a layer no so you add so there's
a skip connection which allows for good
gradient propagation then you do an MLP
so you take this you do an MLP this is
the pointwise operation that I have
already explain to you and uh once you
have an MLP then again you do the same
so you add the the remainder the
residual with the new new input and you
do another L and you stack several of
these blocks together so this is the
structure of an of a transformer okay or
this is the main building block of a
Transformer uh is that clear so you
start with the tension uh you have some
layer normalizations some MLPs and so on
okay so the MLPs are to give you some
and what okay perhaps I should have
explained it so remember that at the end
of the day you need nonlinearities to be
very very general right because uh
without this sort of Ru type or your
nonlinearities need to be something like
this in order to be able to universally
approximate functions unfortunately if
you if would have just taken the self
attention where is if you take the self
attention the only nonlinear processing
that goes on is through the softmax
right now softmax by itself is not good
enough to provide you Universal
approximation because you can ask why do
you need an MLP so softmax is not good
enough you need softmax what it does is
that it provides some spatial mixing
things are mixed in space but you still
need to do some Universal approximation
pointwise and that's why the simplest
thing is to put in a put in a reu or a g
or whatever whatever function that you
have so the MLP the nonlinearity in the
MLP comes from there why is the last
residual
connection uh we add the result of few
bar and not the normalized version you
had there's a question from Lorenzo what
is he asking I don't
understand um U Bar so he's saying that
why do we add the result U Bar what is
you bar
now okay this is the mistake you you
right Lorenzo it is you haed yeah so
I'll correct the mistake uh it it is you
hat means it was just a typo so what you
do is that here you have you hat right
so you have you hat and this is the
object that is added okay so thanks for
pointing out there was a typ of there
okay it's not you it's you hand good so
then uh that that clarifies it but there
is a there is a slight twist here which
is uh that uh so remember that uh and
this is the last point that I'll mention
and then in the next lecture we'll
continue with Transformers that all
these objects these are permutation EnV
variance right because uh there is no no
notion of space here so for instance
self attention I could have reordered
things whatever way if you remember in
self attention means uh there there is
no sense of location here because I
could have just reordered things in a
permutation in variant Manner and I
would have gotten the same output uh
everything else is applied pointwise so
so the notion of mixing here spatial
mixing is completely sort of position
independent okay so there's no sense of
position and this is this is problematic
so in other words whether I give this as
my input means the values this uh this
as my input or something else as my
input uh I just transpose these guys put
them in some random order so this is
meant to be permutation invariant right
I get the same answer so the the sense
of location is completely gone right so
what we have to do in order to in order
to understand this is we have to encode
the position and we have to add
something called positional encodings
okay so this is a very very key part of
transform architectures you have to take
into account position so let let me try
to explain this in a discrete manner
because this is where it is implemented
so what you do is uh so remember let's
let's try to think in terms of
tokens so we have no sense of position
now so all of these are position
independent V1 V2 V3 up to VK and so on
and so forth so now we have a k
dimensional input space right K number
of tokens and we have no sensor position
so what do we do we introduce a sensor
the position by introducing the basis
vectors EK so these are the so-called
one hot
vectors so EK is going to be 0 0 0 1 0
something like this so in addition to
this I have another
input which is capital K
dimensional let me explain that so each
of the
token this is a very poor drawing but
here you also have EK so you have n
dimensional input feature here you have
a uh K capital K dimensional input
feature here so this automatically tells
you essentially that this guy here is
located at the K location so it's sort
of a absolute coordinate system that
you're providing with the token this guy
here is the third location this guy here
is the capital K location and so on so
it provides you some sense of some
notion of position and then of course
you use some MLPs in know to lift it you
know to lift it into the right kind of
Dimensions so in other words uh we we
want so now our input features are end
dimensional from the actual features and
capital K dimensional for the position
so what we are going to do is I don't
understand why I didn't uh do I don't
even know why I said it's D
Bar it's uh there's a mistake it should
be so replace the D Bar with k with
capital K sorry again um I'll correct
this in the corrected slides so D Bar
should be replaced with capital K here
okay so what you do is that you just
take this
um this is this sorry sorry what am I
talking
about there is a mistake let me correct
the mistake so the N here is a capital
so this is correct so we is D cross a k
so you take something which is K
dimensional represent it with d and then
bring it back to Dimensions sorry so I
was I was correct you know I'm sick so
I'm not completely following what I'm
doing but this is correct so this will
give you a learned n dimensional
embedding of or encoding of the position
and this will give you another learned
end dimensional embedding of the
features so this is uh a very general
way in which position can be encoded but
in the original paper they did not even
use this kind of learn they use the
learned and codings and they said ah
learned and codings are no better than
than just using fixed encodings so fixed
encodings essentially is a s cosine
representation of the location number K
so they just say okay the location
number K is represented by S of K over
something okay so you can think of this
as a simplification of positioning so we
need to provide these positional
encodings so the sense of position is
provided in some form or the other and
this gives you the final version of a
transformer block where you have your
inputs and then you have the positional
encoding
which uh and together you go through
multi-head attention you do a layer
normalization MLP layer normalization
and every time you have skip connections
okay so this is sort of the the basic
architecture of Transformers of course
there are some caveats but this is what
we are going to do in the next lecture
so I think I I I stop here uh we have
almost uh we finished almost the
allocated time are there any questions
no so hopefully on uh on Friday I come
in person and if you have any questions
you can always ask me there okay I I
will correct the typos and I will send
the corrected slides which will be
uploaded in due time see you hopefully
on Friday take care bye-bye